is there any changes you guys want to
make going into the next year
i'm just continuing what you're doing
now
i guess just like i don't know for me
new year's resolutions
youtuber new year's resolution i will
probably i'm gonna hit a million subs on
the second channel there's probably
gonna be a point uh because i you know
when the world does open up i do want to
travel a lot more yeah like actually
like have a bit more time to relax so
there'll probably be a point where i'm
uploading a little bit less so i'm not
i'm not really too bothered about at all
i'm i'm just gonna say it now just exp
expect less uploads on the main channel
i think just because yeah for one i want
to put more effort into each video now i
don't want to like be confined to this
once a week schedule and like two you're
not gonna talk about what anime you're
not going to watch no probably not
if i do that'll be on the main on the
second channel where actual anime
content exists
subscribe
but uh yeah i don't know like at least
with the main channel like i think
i know what kind of content i want to
like focus more on on the set on the
main channel from next year but that is
definitely going to force me to not
upload every week yeah just because it's
going to be impossible yeah i think last
year my new year's resolution was to be
more productive and to upload more and
then as i've just said this year i've
kind of realized yeah that i tried i
really did because i went i went like a
good like four months where i had like
three videos a month and i'm just like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just like
before we went to the uk it was like
pretty consistent what's it really yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] you don't watch google
right
it was literally just before the office
move and then and then it took like all
right [ __ ] [ __ ] three weeks
it was around the same time so it was
like the first
the first half of the year um and then i
realized okay my my
resolution was just unsustainable and
i'm like i've accepted that yeah so my
new year's resolution is i want to do
more collabs and it's not going to be on
the main channel which is why i want to
focus more on another channel um because
i've kind of realized collabs just don't
work for the dynamic on my on my main
channel yeah yeah that's that's what
would you dream what about collab
our collab remember that one
that one the one the one collab that
legendary that was skit yeah yeah okay
that was that was a long time ago i was
like i was like three four years you
just hit me under the bus
i mean because like i want to do less
something that's like not scripted and
i'd feel like any anything i script and
collabs uh anything uh anything i do on
my main channel has to be scripted so
that that video was obviously scripted
um i also just wanted like more time to
work on like side projects i want to do
a week-long live stream at least at some
point i'll do it at some point
good luck with avraham i'll do it
somewhere i did three days just double
it
it's a stubble yeah it was double easy
did i not like break you no
three days three days would like easily
break me off like three hours
i think i made a mistake of shouting
during one game too much getting angry
yeah and it [ __ ] my throat for like
the next day and then obviously it
wasn't having any time to heal because i
was just talking all day yeah and so
that was a rookie mistake but do it
again i'm not going to shout as much
not as
but
actually the sleeping in that [ __ ] bed
was kind of uncomfortable i didn't
really get good sleep that was one thing
oh yeah i i i wouldn't with the [ __ ]
thousands of people yeah with a [ __ ]
rave going on in the bathroom it was the
bed the bed sucked
probably just do one night where i just
go and sleep in my nice bed and i'm like
oh i'm rested boys let's get it let's go
come on we must keep streaming yeah yeah
i don't know yeah i want to do that at
some point though yeah and i mean like i
guess like in the case with like trash
days as well like because you know we're
the world is hopefully going to open up
a little more next year yeah we're just
going to be really busy with that [ __ ]
as well like the workload for trash
taste has been upped as well right
because we don't
now we stream every week if you didn't
know um until at least until christmas
comes along which twist
trash takes which would be about now but
uh once the new year rolls along i i i
want to continue the weekly streams yeah
i just work right
but like what that means is that we
we're basically just recording another
podcast every week we have two trash
tastes at this point yeah you have the
trash taste and then the trash is
apparent yeah you guys are getting like
five hours of content which if there
wasn't enough of my schedule already
there's there's another thing to tick
off the main channel
it's another trash taste recording
somebody added up all the run time of
trash station it was longer than like
all of dbc or something
or something like that i believe that i
would still rather watch that
and uh
i've rewatched episodes there and all of
them oh my god regarding trash though um
i we uh we figured out earlier that
we've only uploaded one special this
year
oh yeah which was the cycling special
back in february which we filmed the
year prior
so uh will the figure episode count as a
special that's kind of yeah it's like
half a second it's like a mini special
yeah yeah yeah i guess i guess that's
amazing it's special in nature yeah not
a name
because we're still in the office yeah i
mean we had the cycling special and then
we've had like some mini specials like
the figure special the pc build special
um but i i guess i guess it truly is
like top gear now where we get like we
get like once once a year one big
special yeah and every other week is
just like the normal life two specials a
year yeah that's probably a healthy
amount two yeah i i think two special
yeah well a big portion of this remember
remember when we first started doing
specials we were like
four a year let's do it all right that
ain't happening
well because we had we had like we are
just like
back then we had our main channel and
trash taste and that was it yeah
now we have our main channel you guys
are doing your second channel streaming
trash taste after dark um and then we
got to do our specials on top of that
easy
and people wonder why we want assistance
yeah right
i really i'm like genuinely considering
it for next year i think i think it's
gotten to the point where i actually
will it's it's not a matter of if
i need one or if if i want one it's i
actually need one otherwise i think i'm
going to go insane no i've i've been
trying to look for one as well but i
want i want an assistant who's in japan
which is very hard yeah otherwise i'd
just like [ __ ] fly allen over or
something yeah
um but yeah i am also definitely looking
for an assistant